ohne sitze da guckt euch das an
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück bei roto
glaube ich nehme diese folge nun direkt
am anschluss zur anderen folge auf das
heißt ich konnte ganzen kommentare noch
nicht lesen
mich hat jetzt einfach bock auf noch
eine runde road to glory und habe ich
mir gedacht spielzeit noch eine runde
road to glory und naja jedenfalls nicht
schon mal ganz gut das könnte ich noch
verändern sagt ja der schnell dem pack
ich mal hier rein den sinclair der knopf
mit dem pack ich mal hier nach vorne was
mit dem pack ich auch noch rein ihr
rechtes mittelfeld habe ich glaube ich
gar keinen doch den darf habe ich damit
es nicht schnell was hat er so viel wert
ja ok tempo von 70 nicht so gut also der
länder soll es mal ausruhen den kündigt
theoretischen reinpacken
jetzt aber auch nicht schnell bist
normal
du kommst jetzt für den rhein und den
rest sofort wohl lassen suche gegner
ich wette wir finden oder prozent ein
weil die alle total angstgegner weil die
alle angst vor uns haben
team lohmann ich glaube dass deutsch
okay das wird krass der hat was er hat
wo er wie wie bitte kommt er an kaka wie
viel kohle hat er denn man sieht schon
dass das ein zusammengekaufte system ist
ich weiß nicht wer sonst oder wieviel
skk wert der story die sehr sechsstellig
schon als nicht jeden fall krasse menge
wert na gut denn dahin man da wollte ich
ihn spielen hey okay aber zum glück ist
hier volkert relativ schnell zum glück
habe ich immer noch einen darf und warum
nimmt er den mit dem kopf warum nicht
einfach an meine fresse
wenn ich so schwer hier so jedenfalls
ist das gute bei solchen teams die man
richtig gut sind die können meistens
überhaupt nicht spielen
das denken sich so ja ich habe ein gutes
team
ich krieg da stehen wo wir war das jetzt
kein foul wir denken sich für euch ein
gutes team ich krieg das schon irgendwie
hin
so nach dem motto besser ausgespielt
super ballannahme von sinclair
nein normal
herr war gut super gemacht
das blöde pass aber oder kommt klasse
sie sagen wir gut gemacht er lässt sich
einfach mal fallen und ecke gut ich habe
gedacht ich mache was in seine ecken
taktik aber ich hab keinen plan wie das
geht
ich mache dann mach sondern eine
lehrstunde sage ich mal mein lauf
deutlich vom ball weg großer typ ist das
eigentlich weiß ganz nei schade
vielleicht irgendwann so eine lehrstunde
wo ich mir so tricks und wo ich euch zu
tricks und freistößen bisschen beibringt
freistöße kann ich selber nicht also ich
bringe freistöße 3 und zeigt euch ein
paar tricks zu werden junge oder witzen
die hauen sich gegenseitig um alter wie
bescheuert ist das denn das gesehen im
echten spiel würden sich doch nicht zwei
eigene spieler selbst umhauen
denn sie laufen nicht irgendwie im
zweikampf duell oder so einfach so wenn
sie laufen das kann ich nicht sein
favorit ist schnell aber kann nicht
rütteln
das weiß natürlich wieder super gemacht
also wirklich super klasse pass verdammt
gut gemacht gut gedacht nein nie sein
nun wie viel glück haben die ganzen
gegner denn einfach immer wenn ich
aufnehmen habe ich so eine chance
verwertung von seinem stück toast aber
es ist echt so der typ kann richtig gut
spielen sehr schnell
nein anstatt wir uns zusammen und
hambach hambach hambach scheiße fakt ist
dass mein alter das ist rechtens navas
nein ich glaub's nicht alter der verein
gegangen
wenn er kein innenverteidiger von mir
gewesen ich liebe einfach diese leute
die nichts können aber beispiel hp spiel
habe ich kann auch ein bisschen was
eigentlich hat und deswegen die
selbstverliebte sein oder so aber kommt
verliert einen weil ich mache sogar noch
trick ist reizvoll übrigens ich glaube
ich stelle die kommentatoren auf deutsch
das wäre ein bisschen besser weil damit
sich ein paar leute beschwert ich
verstecke auf englisch
danke bild von ihm
das wäre geil wenn daraus jetzt das tor
entsteht das überhaupt irgendwas
entsteht
mein alter ich drück kopfball taste mehr
geht einfach nicht zum kopfball
scheiß oben seine freistöße scheiße
scheiße scheiße scheiße scheiße scheiße
gut haha nein es kann nicht sein diese
scheiß egal wer kennt die tricks fünf
minuten später junge das ist echt normal
und witzig ist echt mal selber mit
dieser elgato spielen ihr braucht jahre
bis die sein kumpel sieben jahre bis sie
so einen komischen trichter erkannt hat
das ist richtig schrecklich
und ob und dortmund 9 [ __ ] [ __ ]
nein es kann doch nicht sein als er
dieser fakten der typ kriegt nichts auf
freie und mache da so ein wilder desto
komplexer seien so wieder so ein
sonntagsschuss hier und du kannst bei
ihm so dicht reihen durchgehen ich kann
machen was ich will ich komme einfach
immer durch diese nähe war nix quatsch
ist doch kein foul
ich bitte dich schiri brauchst ja nicht
abpfeifen oder so hat ja nicht die beine
weggezogen
quatsch ich werde mich zum eigenen
spieler
das ist hundertprozentig gut
ich liebe diese schiedsrichtern fifa
die kennen einfach die kündigt
unterscheiden was jetzt droht das geld
ist was überhaupt ein foul ist mir nicht
so aufregen alles sehr schnell
da hast du als ich glaube ja in vence
haben wir dann frag mal bei dem auto der
junge das ist elfmeter du verdammter
petermann alter ihr habt es hier schwarz
das bund schwarz auf weiß der folgt mich
zweimal
es ist nie ein voll gewesen ich heule
torwart um und es sofort ein foul
okay das war toll aber die beiden sachen
von er die er nicht gemacht hat wann
auch fouls da braucht ihn jetzt nicht so
ein vom pferd erzählen oder er oder der
schiri oder keine ahnung wer das waren
fouls die müssen gepfiffen werden wenn
man ein roulette macht besteht die
chance vielleicht 30 prozent dass man da
irgendwie noch dran kommt oder so
während 30 prozent chance dar
ohne witz alter guckt euch das an und
ich kriege ich die krise bei solchen
sachen
ich krieg kratzen man ohne scheiß ich
bin einfach nur noch am lachen das ist
einfach nur witzig wie wenig die hier
die chance nutzen ja ich könnte direkt
hier gegen die man schlagen das ist
normal wenn das tor gewesen wären ich
werde so ausgerastet alter ich kann euch
versprechen ich hätte den controller
gegen den bildschirm gehauen
rote karte sah
ende
diese zeit
mechaniker
und 2
bergstedt gemacht
hayward
eschau alter das kann ich nicht wahr
sein oder leute erklärt mir das mal
bitte wie kann so ein behinderter
schpakow ging mit 2 0 führen ja ich will
ja nicht sagen aber torchancen er 22
tore
guckt euch das an ich ungefähr 30 kein
tor
alter es kann nicht wahr sein oder
vor allem die sache ne super
rausgespielt lauf aufs tor zu machen
nutzer fallrückzieher auf dem boden
übers tor das kann ich wahr sein oder
erklärt mir das mal bitte ja bitte
es ist so schwer daran einfach spiel
fortsetzen zu drücken
der treibt es auf die spitze
hallo ich hoffe dass jetzt auf kalter
junge
ja und auf einmal ist er wieder da auf
einmal einen moment da wir jetzt läuft
er damit christus navas herrn denkst
recht und schlecht aussehen was anderes
kann ich mich hallo mein name ist super
player fifa kommunalgemeinschaft auf den
namen super player fifa behindert da
geht es ja wohl nicht so kommen jetzt
macht den wenigstens drei geht aus dem
angriff jetzt bin ich aber sehr sehr
böse alter bub spielte den ball gleich
am wein leute bei mir geht natürlich
keinen kopf bei rein sondern erhält
einfach mal alles immer noch wer kaká
hat es mit fk gut ich habe vorhin schon
gesagt dass ich die die
schiedsrichterleistungen hier sehr
bevorzugt aber so wie ich mein glück
kenne ich die jetzt ähnlich rein
leute der iran ist nicht wie ich gerade
im rating binder
das kann nicht wahr sein wer wäre ich
gerade nicht am aufnehmen er ich hatte
schon so umgeschrieben
ich hätte die ganze bude zusammen
geschrieben hat ist aber gerade abends
meine eltern sind deswegen lasse ich das
gerade ihr habt mich glaube ich noch nie
so wütend in einem video gesehen jetzt
macht er natürlich den kopf bald vorbei
13 meter-riesen drinstehen hat die kann
nur so kommt er denn bitte da zum schuss
das war gerade mein controllern habe ich
gerade auf einem teppich und dann gegen
die wand geworfen weil ich muss man sie
darum wie kann ein spieler so schlecht
sein und trotzdem tore machen ja wie
geht das bitte erklärt mir das kann man
so schlecht sein man wie kann man so ein
behinderte
jetzt sieht der mitte hundertprozentig
oder er pflanzt ganz naiv lang weil er
zehn milliarden 10 milliarden meter hohe
spieler
ich war kurz davor auszuholen alter
mediator lg zehn sekunden später und
passt es zehn minuten später deswegen
jetzt noch ein tor rein sauber
so läuft das ab meine freunde so läuft
das hier so macht das spaß
so hat das richtig spaß fifa ich werde
nicht meter gehalten ich habe verrückt
darüber gezogen habe nach mittertor
pfosten getroffen alter was will der
eigentlich noch wenn der mir nicht der
schreib danke für den sieg oder sowas
mehr dann ist es aber ein ganz ganz
sozialer mensch
ausgedehnte selbst
wieso gibt es kann nicht wahr sein
wieso geht so ein ball nicht rein alter
ich habe ich gedacht okay 42 dass es
locker dass wir zwei wir haben noch 25
minuten vielleicht schaffen wir das
sogar noch und dann geht er nicht ein
alter es kann auch nicht was im bitte
erklärt mir dass leute wie wenig chancen
kann man bitte nutzen als spieler eine
feier wie schleck wenn das junge meine
spieler haben sich gegenseitig wieder
mal guckt euch das bitte an guckt es
euch an den ball hätte ich locker gehabt
dass es nicht die muße haben meine
spieler läuft zurück und die der torwart
hat den spieler um ja ich glaube es echt
nicht alter was hier mittlerweile abgeht
richtig kriegs langsam nicht mehr meinen
kopf rein das ist richtig es ist langsam
echt schon psycho immer wenn ich die
verschiedene eine chance verwertete
sinkt auf ein minimum das den stoffen
auf negative es kann einfach nicht wahr
sein
er macht zwei kopfballtore und dann noch
so zwei richtig geld kopfballtoren ich
hätte locker schon zehn tore machen
können 100 prozentig man so denn der
gleich nicht reingehen
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht weiter ich
weiß nicht weiter wenn der reingeht
es kann nicht wahr sein dass es solche
verdammten pizza gibt einfach nur auf
der welt das kann nicht wahr sein schuss
aus 30 metern rein
ein schuss aus 30 metern torwart zehn
sekunden lang der weisen dem bei sieht
der geht bei ihnen natürlich rein jetzt
wieder 1000 jahre laufen sagte ich
gucken dass man den skilift ohren hatte
ich bin zehn jahre alten ich kann
spielen
mit 200 euro und das gebe ich dann für
vier teams aus sorry dass ich gerade so
ein bisschen am rating bin aber ich
glaube ihr würdet nicht anders ergehen
wenn du gegen so eine person spielen
würde und jetzt schreibt mir nicht in
die kommentare älter bist voller kraft
beim zocken bin ich halt meine fresse
aber auch nur bei fifa weil sonst sonst
nix scheiß auf alle ballerspiele horror
spiele das ist nur bei fifa sowie kann
man dagegen einen liegenden spieler
bitte den ball verlieren ich bin jetzt
einfach nur gerne umbauen weil das
einfach sowas von verdient hat guckt
euch das doch an was ist das das ist nix
der kann nix der g3 flankt und macht
noch ein tor
das kann nicht sein immer schlank und
dann so behinderte toren
es kann einfach leute ich bin mir nicht
mal sicher ob ich die volle ob ich das
ja alles hochladen werde ich bin einfach
nur am rutschen man jungen alleine ich
dieses ergebnis schon sehr 61 alter ich
bin kurz davor mein komplettes team
alles mit ihm zu verkaufen und alles an
nagel zu hängen
kann ich mein vernünftigen einwurf und
schießt gegen mich sechs tore alter
jeder schnell drauf man wenigstens ein
drittes tor jetzt sitze ich schon
bisschen überheblich was er da abziehen
ich pass zurück zum torwart halte er den
ball passt da unten damit er wieder
durchlaufen kann dann schickt damit eine
flanke oder gibt einfach direkt im werk
auch sehr klug guck mal das sind
kombinationen und was macht er dagegen
einfach nur kacke und warum gehen solche
bälle denn bisher steht frei vorm tonne
bis das frei vorm tor nicht alexander
frei sondern er steht einfach frei vorm
tor bitte verbindung kacka kacka kacka
walter ich kriege es nicht nur freie man
guckt euch das noch an was sind das der
kann doch nix bitte erklärt mir einfach
wie er schafft gegen mich sechs tore zu
schießen wenig sagen aber das sind schön
herausgespielte tore
danke endlich auch mal was vernünftiges
für mich hier zu 63 wenn das ganze in
der 60 minute passierte dann hätte ich
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen das
ganze von wegen jahren drei tore schafft
man vielleicht noch in der zeit aber
jetzt nämlich gerade alles so ein
bisschen wie anderen chelsea gegen den
yen haben am wochenende gespielt west
ham glaube ich das spiel stand nach 30
minuten 4 zu 3
und ich frage mich nur so alt wie geht
das mittel also es kann eigentlich war
dann auf einmal schießen wir drei toren
fünf minuten junge behinderte spiel
erlebt oder witz das kann echt ich war
sein
das spiel ist jetzt vorbei von daher
brauchen wir uns jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht mehr anstrengen aber ich frag mich
trotzdem wie sowas sein kann dass selbst
sechs tore gegen mich schießt freue mich
echt naja ok 6 zu 4 ist ein sehr
komisches ergebnis wir haben gerade erst
drei tore ein paar minuten geschlossen
ist es echt krass gewesen ich nicht
gedacht warum hole ich eigentlich jetzt
schon wieder den torwart raus das war so
schön sondern reflex zeichnung wenn ich
wette darauf auch wieder einstellen weil
es einfach die gleiche geschichte
gewesen der untenrum rein flanken dann
reinkommen 18 9 auf diese 90
naja ein krasses spiel auf jeden fall
ich bin ziemlich gerät tut mir leid
leute aber das ist einfach so wenig
verspielt und ihr wolltet es so die
folge wird auch rage heißen
na ja der ist einfach zu dumm es zu
drücken ich schreibe dir eine schöne
nachricht mich schon ein bisschen ab
gerät nach den drei toren der aber ok to
play ließ wollte ich wieder schreiben
bitte lernspielen alt also nach dem
motto
jetzt hat das erst begriffen wie viele
punkte haben wir hätten mehr punkte als
vorher